these LED tubes come in a selection of
lengths they're designed to be a modern
energy-saving alternative to fluorescent
tube light fixtures the manufacturing
process begins with the printed circuit
board printed means the board has a
network of conductive copper lines and
rectangular paths it's designed to
electrically linked components a
technician places the circuit board on a
track which varies it to the first
computer-guided machine on the line the
machine covers the board with the metal
stencil the stencil has openings
matching the locations where the
electronic components will be mounted to
the board the machine spreads a layer of
lead-free tin alloy solder over the
stencil this apply solder to the board
only where the components go the next
computer-guided machine on the line
mounts the first of those components the
light emitting diodes or LEDs they're
composed of a microchip coated with a
chemical phosphor and come in different
sizes colors and light outputs the
factory programs the machines chip
shooter to pick the required LEDs off
supply reels and place them on the
solder coated locations on the circuit
board the chip shooter works at an
astonishing speed placing up to 40,000
LEDs per hour
a camera trained on the board verifies
that every LEDs position is dead on the
circuit board moves to a third
computer-guided machine for the next
electronic component the terminals they
receive the electric current to power
the LED light tube the machine picks up
one terminal at a time and places it on
the circuit board the circuit board
moves into the final machine on this
line a tunnel of it the temperature
inside peaks at about 460 degrees
Fahrenheit the heat melts the solder
fusing the components to the board Sider
is both adhesive and conductive the bond
connects the components to the board's
copper electrical network for the high
light output to their making in this run
each board is comprised of eight strips
each strip has dual rows of LEDs they
snap them into 12 inch strips the tube
lengths are making requires four strips
a technician slides one with the
terminal and three without into an
aluminum track he gives them a visual
inspection then solder the strips to
each other